joe rogan
joe rogan is giving great news to the
republicans we've seen a lot of good
signs in recent months that they're
going to do well in the midterm
elections the generic congressional
ballot the misery index the simple fact
that it's the first midterm of a new
president all of that points to good
news for the party out of power
yesterday the gop received a better omen
than all of those others combined
joe rogan told his audience that he
wants them to vote republican
no one who was alive today had ever
experienced a true pandemic
and i'm hoping that now that this is
over people are going to
you know recognize that some serious
errors were made and not repeat those
that's the best you can get out of it so
what do you tell those people vote
republican
[Laughter]
that's what a lot of them are going to
do anyway yeah yeah oh yeah i mean more
than a million people transferred over
to the republican party
uh i think in 2021 alone find out what
that number is
but you know you look at guys like ron
desantis who kept florida open and had
some pretty reasonable policies in terms
of like what what to do about covet and
you know he mapped it out on television
he was
you know widely criticized for this
where he was saying like we need to
protect our elders we need to you know
make sure that medical care is available
for those people and everyone else you
should be able to do whatever you want
to do protect your freedom
those 55 seconds from joe rogan are more
important than any
policy nerd analysis more important than
10 000 pages of data from every
four-eyed pollster in america because
joe rogan is
the generic voter
joe rogan speaks two and four
more people than just about anyone else
in america as goes joe rogan
so goes
the country
in many ways after 18 months of record
high inflation of foreign policy
disaster of mass illegal migration of a
collapse in law and order and a creeping
sense that our institutions of
government are being rigged and wielded
by democrats for their own personal gain
whether it's the fbi pressuring facebook
to censor the hunter biden laptop story
whether it's the doj busting through
donald trump's store at mar-a-lago the
american people right now are signaling
in every way they can that they intend
to vote the bums out
and yet
only one thing is certain
the more that the people express support
for republicans in november
the more the establishment will smear
them all as a threat to democracy i'm
michael knowles is the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the fable
sphere who says until such time
michael knowles will use
the stakes have never been higher
as a segway into good ranchers my life
will continue to be missing something
that's a really
really good idea i
am ashamed of myself
that i had not thought of it before
you know this is my job okay and we're
living through a very very tough time in
american history and the stakes
have never been higher
which is why you got to check out good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles because this is
the last chance
my favorite meat delivery service good
ranchers has been running a back to
school give back program this month with
the goal of donating 100 000 high
quality meals to children in need with
labor day just around the corner this is
your last chance to enter for the chance
to win 30 minutes with me via zoom on
september 30th we are calling it a meet
and greet do you get it go to
goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles at checkout you
will get 30 bucks off plus free shipping
you can subscribe if you want and lock
in your price which is insane you'll
inflation-proof your meals for life you
can order the one-off box of meat if you
want but you if you subscribe it's just
absolutely wild the savings that you
will see and you'll be automatically
entered to win 30 minutes of all access
meet and greet with me on september 30th
this offer ends tomorrow august 31st
that's goodranchers.com knowles use
codenoles at checkout and i'll see you
at the meet
and greet the joe rogan thing is very
very important now you might say well no
michael joe rogan doesn't pick the
president for goodness sakes the man was
a bernie bro and then he kind of liked
trump and then i don't know he has views
that sometimes don't totally jive with
one another sure that's true
just like the generic voter
most americans are not spending every
waking moment doing all sorts of
political analysis with their nose and
spreadsheets and everything like that
most americans are doing other things
joe rogan is a good example of this joe
rogan seems to care a lot more about mma
and the haitian oregano than he does
about the nitty-gritty of politics but
like all americans like the generic
voter he has political preferences and
political views and he's he's not
particularly firmly rooted in those
political views they change a little bit
with changing circumstances and there's
something about that that's very very
healthy and joe rogan right now is not
mincing words at all he's saying what
would i do right now i would vote
republican of course of course the libs
are destroying the economy they're
they're stomping on a lot of our
traditional rights and freedoms and way
of life and they're they're failing on
pretty much every issue you can see that
in all of the polls
and
and they're compromising our
institutions of government and they're
raiding homes they're doing all sorts of
nonsense and so rogan's looking at that
he's saying yeah no more of that let's
do the other guy let's go back
to the other guys
and donald trump is not being quiet
about this either trump just tweeted out
he didn't tweet out actually because
he's still not allowed on twitter
because the silicon valley oligarchs
booted the then sitting duly elected
president of the united states out of
the public square another reason why
people i think are turning against the
libs and
trump tweets out
now it comes out conclusively that the
fbi buried the hunter biden laptop story
before the election knowing that if they
didn't trump would have easily won the
2020 presidential election this is
massive fraud and election interference
at a level never before seen in our
country remedy declare the rightful
winner or and this would be the minimal
solution declare the 2020 election
irreparably compromised and a new
election uh should be held immediately
that would be great i would really enjoy
that with that it were so simple uh
that's not going to happen
they're not going to declare the 2020
election null and void but it would be
great i'd love it if they did i agree i
think the election was rigged to the
hilt i think there were all sorts of
shenanigans in a number of cases it was
overtly illegal and unconstitutional so
yeah i'm with trump on this you're going
to hear you're going to hear in coming
weeks and months and moving into 2024 a
lot of republicans turn on trump
and they're going to make some
observations they're going to say oh
trump he talks too much he's a
distraction oh trump we got to move on
from trump
a lot of the people who are going to be
saying that didn't like trump in the
first place and they really hated him in
2016. and so you're going to see a
rehashing of a lot of the fights over
trump from 2016.
now do i think this is particularly
helpful these kinds of tweets and
truth social posts or whatever i don't
know i mean in a way it kind of riles up
the base is what he's telling them is
not hey we're gonna have a redo of the
2020 election
before 2024. what he's what he's telling
them is hey this was wrong this was
fraud what they perpetrated on us was
very very wrong and you should be angry
about it and to that i agree i think
that's true i think it was wrong to
extend election day to election month i
think it was wrong to push the
widespread mail-in ballots i think it
was wrong to lock the whole country down
for kovid which unfortunately donald
trump was a part of but it was certainly
wrong to extend that through into the
elections yeah i think that's true
you're not going to hear me turn on
trump
okay
yeah is ron desantis a great potential
candidate for president absolutely i
think he'd make a great president
probably is ted cruz a great candidate
for president i certainly think he is i
do a podcast with the guy i think he's
he's an excellent conservative leader i
think he'd make a great president are
there other republicans even who could
do a great job
yeah yeah i think so
but i'm not gonna
i'm not going to
make that an excuse to go against trump
i think trump is the greatest republican
president in my lifetime i think the guy
got roe v wade overruled and if the guy
wants to run for president more power to
him
i will support the republican nominee in
2024 unless the republican nominee is
liz cheney or somebody i will support
the republican nominee but i'm not going
to whine and cry and say trump shouldn't
run in 2024 absolutely he should run if
he wants to
he's still got a lot of support
and if the man wants to run and the man
can beat out the other guys in the
primary then that means he's he's the
man for the nomination
that means that he won the process that
it takes to become the nominee
and
i'm i'm totally fine with that i would
gleefully vote for donald trump a third
time
speaking of voting
there's a lot of oppression in the
country not just the oppression of the
conservatives at the hands of the libs
who changed the election rules no no i'm
talking about the oppression
of celebrities and music stars at the
video music awards i'm talking about the
oppression of lizzo
who as she's accepting her award
she reminds everyone they need to go out
and vote to stop all the oppression
i don't know
what uh music video for good means but i
do know what your vote means and that's
a
lot
your vote means everything
to me
it means everything to making a change
in this country
[Music]
so remember when you're voting for your
favorite artist vote to change some of
these laws that are oppressing us
now of course lizzo is probably the
single least oppressed person on earth
she is maybe she's oppressed by our
decadent culture
but she's certainly not oppressed by
any of the things that ordinarily would
would be considered oppressive she has
as many political rights as she wants
she has the abundance of material goods
she she can do whatever she pleases
that's why lizzo is not being detailed
here she's not she's not saying what
laws we should vote against she's not
even saying what candidates to vote
against she's not saying what is
oppressing her
she's just saying yeah it's it's
oppressive you got to go vote
it's just the kind of
most ridiculous conclusion of puff
daddy's
campaign from 2004 vote or die
remember he had that campaign he said
vote or die
because they were trying to kick george
bush out of office
you say uh i don't think those are the
only two options
i don't think a consequence of not
voting will be that we all die i doubt
that
it's just so vague it's just these
people being used as parrots for the
entrenched powers for the liberal
establishment a woman wearing a very
fancy expensive dress holding a gold
statue saying i'm so oppressed be sure
to go out and vote against the bad guys
for the good guys because of the
oppression and it's not
really persuasive anymore if it ever was
persuasive which i don't think it was
don't forget puff daddy's vote or die
thing did not work
but if it ever was persuasive i just
think advances in technology so that now
we're not just beholden to the main news
networks we actually do research
ourselves
that really dealt a tough blow to the
establishment uh changes in
power the fact the fact now that these
libs who used to be
on the fringes of power who used to be
able to somewhat credibly claim that
they were fighting the man now that they
just dominate the entire establishment
the fact that
whenever you see the resistance and blm
and the pride flag it's always being
pushed by gazillion dollar corporations
and institutions of the government that
i think has changed it and the fact that
these guys have lost the common sense
the fact that the libs push transiting
the kids and killing all the babies and
opening up all of our borders and
destroying our currency and locking us
all down over the wu flu the the the and
the fact that that they won't even close
down gay bath houses to stop monkey pox
i mean just
on issue after issue after issue the
libs have so lost the common sense
that they lose the generic voter okay
and they and they lose joe rogan and
they lose the people who represent the
kind of
open-minded middle in american politics
and and no speeches from lizzo are going
to change that
you know this is this is the fight that
we're in this is the life we're living
and someday we're going to die which is
why you got to get a will right now go
to epicwill.com and use code knowles
unless you're not going to die are you
you're not going to die you're that one
person who no we're all going to die no
one here gets out alive not in this
world that's why you need a will you've
heard me talk a lot on this show about
how the libs are coming for your kids
through the public school system through
mainstream entertainment kids content as
a parent you may be doing everything you
can to protect your child from the
left's not so secret agenda remember
when a certain
company in florida was talking about
that but if you don't have a will in
place designated who will take over as
parental guardian should something
happen to you then the libs are going to
intervene and they're going to take your
kids and indoctrinate them and
completely disrespect what you would
have wanted that's why you got to check
out epic will epic will is an online
will platform it costs less than your
next trip to the store they can set you
up with a will in as little as five
minutes starting at just 119 bucks
plus right now you can save 10 when you
go to epic will.com and use code knowles
it's so simple take five minutes tonight
write a will ensuring that your kids
will be raised the way you intend in the
event that something happens to you go
to epicwheel.com
use code knowles today to save 10
speaking of
weird hang-ups about eating
video went viral yesterday
on the streets of new york
an animal rights activist versus a
regular guy eating a kebab and this
video i think this sums up the
difference between the left and the
right in america
is right in his face and there's the guy
you're gonna die
guys just standing there sunglasses on
eating this kebab
you and your small
and your way of
killing animals and it feels good
you have all the blood on your face
he's not saying anything he's just
eating that kebab
this is it this is what politics looks
like right now to the generic voter
the libs are the screaming
shrieking hyena animal rights activists
losing their minds because a man is
eating a street kebab on the sidewalk in
new york and then the conservatives look
like the just the guy in the t-shirt
with the sunglasses trying to enjoy his
kabob quietly
not not really all that provocative just
eating his lunch that's what it looks
like right now
it didn't always look like that but
that's what it looks like right now
when the libs wail and shriek and cry
about the importance of of having
five-year-olds watch drag queen shows
they look like the shrieking animal
rights lady when the libs
shriek and cry and scream about the
importance of flooding the country with
illegal aliens they look like the crazy
animal rights lady when the libs wear 17
different masks and have 152 injections
of the fouchy algae they look like the
crazy animal rights lady and then all
the rest of us are here and what do we
say most conservatives right now are
they're not articulating some super
ethereal academic
political ideology they're just saying
hey maybe don't chop the kids genitals
off maybe don't
or if you're gonna like wait a little
while at least right huh maybe let's not
kill all the kids it's not in the
constitution and it's probably wrong
don't you think
hey ma i don't know i maybe the fifth
shot of the experimental mrna drug maybe
i don't need that to prevent the mild
cough
they seem really really reasonable and
moderate right now which the the right
wing does not always seem but it does
right now that's why they're winning
over people like joe rogan
that's why they're winning over the
middle of the road voter
that's why liz cheney has a little bit
of a career right now she's not taking
any votes away from the right from the
republicans she's taking votes away from
the democrats
because she is effectively a democrat
and she's attacking trump but she's
prying off a decent percentage of the
moderate democrats that's why the polls
are showing if she were to run as for
president in 2024
she would she would single-handedly
swing the election to trump against
biden
speaking of eating this is a story i've
been waiting to get to for a while
and cnn has given me the opportunity
headline from cnn
mealworm seasoning scientists explore
creepy crawly flavoring to
satisfy meat cravings
would you like some meaty savory
mealworm powder seasoning with your food
it's a question you might soon be
hearing at the dinner table or at least
that's the hope of the scientists at
south korea's wong kuang university
that's right
the the research that they're working on
is a response to the dietary demands of
a growing global population in the
looming climate crisis and the argument
is
that because of the sun monster and
because people are having babies
we all have to eat bugs
there has been a really weird push from
the libs to make us all eat bugs there
was that video that came out a couple of
months ago that of all the celebrities
eating bugs
there are articles that pop up in the
mainstream media constantly talking
about how we need to eat crickets now we
need to eat meal worms we have to do it
why first of all when we talk about the
growing population the population in the
west is dying the united states has had
a dying population for 50 years so our
population is not growing that's why we
have to flood the country with illegal
aliens to art and legal immigrants for
that matter to artificially proper
economy up so the population growth is
not a big problem
and the idea that the sun monster is
forcing us to
to eat
bugs is insane if anything a little
extra heat a little extra sunshine is
going to improve conditions for ranching
and farming so what's this all about
what this is all about
is not
the sun monster or any of the doomsday
predictions that the libs always have
global warming global cooling the
population bomb remember that they're
talking they're worried about population
now 50 years ago in 1970 the libs
predicted in a very famous book by paul
ehrlich called the population bomb
that
the the world population within the
ensuing the following 10 years would
grow and it would cause mass famine and
this was unavoidable and that's why we
needed forced sterilization and
contraception and that didn't happen
today the world population has doubled
malnutrition is at an all-time low
so that that was all just fake news but
whatever it is the doomsday predictions
of the global warming and the global
cooling and the population bomb and all
the rest of it and the ozone layer and
acid rain and all the other things they
don't ever destroy the world
we're now several years into aoc's
prediction the world's going to end in
10 years i think we're going to be fine
we're now well past prince charles's
prediction that the world was going to
end a couple of years ago
what is this about the reason they want
us to eat bugs is because it's gross
the reason they want us to eat bugs is
the same reason that catholics don't
it's not the same reason but it's the
same principle as to why catholics don't
eat meat on fridays it's the same
principle why people of all religious
backgrounds fast sometimes or eat eat
food that can be bitter or unpleasant at
some times for for the purposes of
spiritual discipline the reason that
they want us to eat bugs is because of
how yucky they are because it breaks a
taboo
it's it's not that
we need to eat the bugs to save the
planet and as a consequence of that it's
going to break our taboos the libs want
us to break the taboos because the libs
don't like western culture and they
don't like our traditional ways of life
and they don't like our traditional
religion and they want us to take part
in their new weirdo culture that's based
on their weirdo new age environmentalist
religion and so to be inducted into that
and to train in a spiritual discipline
for that they want us to eat the bugs
there is
zero reason economically ecologically no
reason in the west especially in america
that we need to eat the bugs they just
want us to do it so that we're in the
cult with them
it's the bugs are much more a symbol
than they are a source of protein elon
musk just made a great observation about
this elon musk who is a big supporter of
renewable electric energy obviously
makes a lot of money on electric cars
elon musk who believes in global warming
and climate change
during a recent energy conference in
norway musk pointed out quote
some additional exploration of oil and
gas resources is warranted at this time
so unlike a lot of the other
environmentalist libs he's saying no no
we're not just going to get off of gas
and oil he says realistically i think we
need to use oil and gas in the short
term because otherwise civilization will
crumble one of the biggest challenges
the world has ever faced is the
transition to sustainable energy and to
a sustainable economy this will take
some decades to complete
great observation and it reminds us why
the libs are erecting all those stupid
windmills that kill the birds and don't
really produce any energy green energy
doesn't really work okay when you look
at the efficiency when you look at the
energy output it is absolutely nothing
compared to oil and gas and certainly
compared to nuclear power if the libs
were really just interested in
generating abundant cheap sustainable
energy they would build nuclear power
plants and yet the libs are not doing
that they're vehemently opposed to that
if the libs wanted
cheap abundant energy that contrary to
popular belief is not going to run out
anytime soon
probably anytime at all
they would use fossil fuels
but that's not what they want with the
libs are really after is making us kind
of sacrifice making us feel the pinch
making us go through a kind of spiritual
discipline just like eating the bugs
they want us to
to
turn off turn off our energy and to stop
traveling as far and to stop doing as
much and to stop using gas and to not
even consider doing nuclear energy
because it hurts when they build those
windmills
they're not building a source of
sustainable energy they're just building
a religious icon there it's it's it's
just the modern version of an ancient
egyptian obelisk with a weird little
spinny thing on top that's what it's
about the primary function of the of the
windmills and all of the other monuments
to environmentalism
is as a symbol is as a monument to the
new kind of cult the new kind of
religion well we used to build big
crosses we used to build statues of
christ the redeemer while we used to
build
even outside of christianity we used to
build ziggurats and and pyramids and
giant weird obelisks now we build these
monuments to the new gods of
environmentalism it's just a weird
creepy cult and it drives people just as
nuts as the
animal rights activists screaming at the
shish kebab guy on the streets of new
york we've got to protect ourselves from
these lunatics that's why you've got to
check out ring
summer is busy people are away from home
quite a bit i was just gallivanting all
over the place i was obviously away from
home when we were in the hospital my
wife giving birth to my new kid one of
the ways that i feel safe
is ring
ring especially not just the video
doorbell gotta love the video doorbell
you know that you can see and speak to
whoever is at your doorstep no matter
where you are in the world did you know
they have an award-winning alarm did you
know even further they've got ring alarm
pro which cnet calls a giant leap for
home security protects your doors walls
your windows the everything you know in
your physical home but it will also
protect your digital home as well
because we live so much of our lives
online there are data flying through our
homes you want to protect all of those
things ring alarm pro will allow you to
do it believe it or not i know this is
going to come as a shock sometimes
occasionally even i get some threats you
know even i whom everyone loves so and i
i really really feel
safe in large part thanks to ring so do
it protect your digital life protect
your physical life go to ring right now
this busy summer season gopro
be a pro like me get ring alarm pro
learn more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles
speaking of unnecessary pain and
suffering
there is a weird kind of contradiction
in u.s policy right now
in order for a foreigner to get into the
united states not for an american to get
back into the united states but for a
foreigner to get into the united states
on an airplane they need to show proof
of vaccination
that they have received the fauchiachi
against covid19
however
in order for a guatemalan peasant to get
into the united states he just has to
cross the rio grande and he's not going
to be checked for covet and he's not
going to be stopped at the border and
he's not only going to be ushered in
they're probably going to put him on an
airplane and ship him somewhere into the
middle of the country if greg abbott
doesn't get to him first and ship him to
washington d.c
what's up with that why is it the case
that visitors to the united states and
legal immigrants to the united states
have to have the covid vaccine and if
they don't they're a threat and a danger
to public health
but the millions of illegal aliens
pouring across our southern border they
don't pose any risk at all don't worry
no tests no shots let them write in
that's what peter ducey asked yesterday
of the white house press secretary
corrine jean-pierre during the press
briefing somebody unvaccinated comes
over
on a plane you say that's not okay
somebody walks into texas or arizona
unvaccinated they're allowed to stay
why but that's not how it works like we
actually no i know that that's not what
you guys want to happen but that is what
what has happened but that's not it's
not like somebody walks over and
that's not that's not how exactly what's
happening
we
thousands of people are walking in a day
some of them
turn themselves over some of them are
caught tens of thousands a week are not
that is what is happening so
let me just lay out what we have done
under this administration
we have installed new border technology
and set up joint protocols with mexico
and guatemala
i love that her first reaction is that's
not what's happening no
because she doesn't know her own
policies she in the same press briefing
she stumbled on the status of title 42
which is one of the trump-era border
policies that joe biden got rid of she
didn't even know the status of that
anymore and she didn't know that people
who fly into the country have to have
the vaccines while the people who cross
the border illegally don't and so peter
ducey is there not merely asking
questions for her to clarify he is
clarifying it for her he's saying no no
no this is what's happening that's not
what's happening peter no
karina literally that is what's
happening
oh uh
okay here are my talking points
here are all of my talking points and
what it speaks to
is something that is really irritating
the generic voter namely the fact that
we have a two-tier system of justice in
america
that there are two different sets of
rules you get the privileged people and
then you get the people who get punished
that's it
privilege and punishment
and i think your generic voter such as
he is
whatever he thinks about immigration
whatever he thinks about kovid whatever
he thinks about the vaccines or dr fauci
or any of the rest of them
he's going to look at that and say well
that's not fair
that's that's not fair that the guys who
break our laws across the border they
get to come in without the vaccine
but the businessmen and the tourists and
the legal immigrants
don't
same issue with the student loans
in principle i don't think that
the the government has absolutely no
right whatsoever to forgive student
loans i think it's a stupid policy i
don't think they should forgive the
student loans but the government can do
that that's the sort of thing a
government can do if certainly if they
follow the right legislative channels
sure you might make an argument that
it's really important for the future of
america for the common good for national
security for human flourishing
to uh pay off
people's student loan debt because that
will encourage more people to go to
college and it's more important to pay
that off than i don't know to pay off
farm loans or to pay off small business
loans again i don't think that's true
but i could at least see how you could
make that argument within the political
order
but
that political argument even if that
political argument did hold water it
doesn't work on the campaign trail in
the public square to the generic voter i
think the generic voter's going to look
at that he's going to say that's not
fair
that's not fair
that one group gets special privileges
when their votes get bought and the
other group gets punished that's not
fair and i don't like that
this is coming up right now because the
tennis player novak djokovic withdrew
from the u.s open over the vaccine
requirement
and this isn't this is another important
way to appeal to generic voters is talk
about normal things don't talk about
abstract political philosophy talk about
sports talk about the u.s open talk
about things in the popular culture
and so especially even if you don't give
a damn about the the vaccine
requirements and illegal immigration you
look at that and you say look it's
ridiculous that this guy novak djokovic
who's like a very serious athlete he's
obviously very healthy
he doesn't need the vaccine
is being kept away from this big
tournament that's ridiculous and the
party that's keeping him away they've
lost the plot they've lost the common
sense and the party that's encouraging
to come in i'm more with those guys
speaking of illegal things speaking of
criminals the wisconsin democrat
candidate for senate mandela barnes
it just keeps getting more and more
radical we talked about him a little bit
yesterday he's really really out there
well now there's a new video of him that
has surfaced
describing that the way that he would
really
uh reform our political system is he
would correct the great injustice
that
prisoners
inmates are not allowed to vote
we're not talking about people who get
to uh make decisions we're talking about
incarcerated individuals who don't have
a right to vote uh which is unfortunate
itself and another conversation
that's the new word by the way new new
political correctness just dropped it's
incarcerated individuals excuse me
someone needs to go call up charles
manson you know as a member as a
representative of the incarcerated
individuals community
maybe we should get let's get jeffrey
dahmer out here as a as the spokesman
for the incarcerated individuals no
they're they're criminals
they're inmates they haven't even paid
their debt to society yet
and they're not even allowed to vote
right they're not allowed to vote
because they they broke the law and they
are in the process of paying back that
debt and so
the the very reason that they are in
prison is because they
attacked justice they attacked our
political order so no
certainly not while they were paying
that debt back and in most sane
societies including afterward you don't
just get your full rights to participate
in the political order again that
undermines the political order i never
i never want to hear the dems talk about
rule of law again i never bought it it
was always ridiculous
it really began in earnest after january
6 but they were talking about it all
throughout the trump administration
i said oh no
the horn hat guy danced around the
capitol this is a threat to the rule of
law
guys you
you you all spent eight months burning
the country down during blm
your elected leaders bailed out the
rioters
i don't i think i think that was a
greater threat to the rule of law
than the horn hat guy
well no but the donald trump had a phone
call with ukraine it's a threat to the
rule of law i don't
how is that a threat to the rule of law
the biden family actually peddled
american influence on ukraine while
biden was the point man on ukraine and
got
over 50 000 a month in in bribes for it
that no that wasn't a threat it's just
it's all just so disingenuous it's so
preposterous and the fact that now the
democrats are actually the party have
let all the criminals out of prison
i think ends any claim that they could
possibly make about defending the rule
of law they never want to defend the
rule of law what they want to do
is
is destroy the rule of law and increase
tyranny around the country and they do
it for a political reason it's not just
because they're like the joker and they
want to watch the world burn the reason
they want to do that is because it
affords them an opportunity then to
crack down and when they crack down they
can take more power and that further
entrenches them where they want to be
speaking of the rule of law got to give
bill maher credit
i am not one of those conservatives that
is constantly trying to give credit to
the moderates and the libertarians and
the squishes and the you know he's one
of those classical smart liberals uh i i
think that conservatives have a lot of
big disagreements even with the
classical liberals but bill maher just
made a really good point he was on his
show and he said look i'm i'm
pro-abortion but you guys gotta cut it
out with your stupid comments and your
stupid slogans about if you're you know
if you're pro-life just don't get an
abortion because that doesn't make any
sense
i'm more pro-choice than you could
imagine
i don't think life is always precious
most people don't think that what i'm
saying is you shouldn't say to the other
side you people hate women they don't
hate women they just think it's murder
and if you think it's murder then you
can't go well except for people with a
vagina they can commit murder i don't
think it's murder but they legitimately
do
thank you thank you bill i appreciate it
bill maher might be the last honest
pro-abortion person on the left
naomi wolfe made a similar point she
actually went even a little bit further
in the 90s
she was then a much more left-leaning
feminist author and naomi wolf said look
we got to admit that the baby is a baby
and the baby's alive and we legal
abortion we should have it but we just
have to admit that the woman is killing
the baby in his full humanity
okay you have if you want to defend
abortion that's what you have to do and
i was just on a tv show a
few weeks ago with a liberal brian tyler
cohen and he used these these slogans
and i just thought it's so
frivolous as i pointed out on the show
he says if you don't want an abortion
just don't get an abortion it's not your
business it's not your choice it's not
your it's not your right and you just
think buddy you're not even
maybe you support abortion but
at at least engage with the actual topic
at hand
my claim is that abortion is morally
equivalent to murder because the baby is
a baby
and so you ha you have to if that's the
claim if that's the center point of the
of the issue then you've got to at least
in some way engage with it
and you can argue you can try to argue
that the baby's not a baby that's not
going to work you can try to argue that
the the baby's not alive that's not
going to work and so the only thing
you're left with is what bill maher
finally comes down to which is he says
look i don't really care
i don't i don't mind it i think we
should be able to kill these things but
but if you're pro-life that's not what
you believe and so you've got to be
consistent you've got to get rid of
these dumb slogans in large part because
these dumb slogans
are not
really persuasive
anymore
you know the corporate media
not only control what they want you to
know
but their agenda means the news is
presented in a biased way
you know it
i know it we all know it
thankfully there is a way to get the
most important news of the day without
that crazy narrative and that is by
listening to one of the top news
podcasts morning wire
new episodes are available every morning
seven days a week they cover stories
other media outlets will not touch check
out morningwire on apple podcast spotify
dailywear plus or wherever you listen to
podcasts
some people are not able to see past
the tired old slogans one of those
people
would be adam kinzinger the
nominal republican who just got booted
out of congress because he's a big
squish lib who spends all of his time
sucking up to democrats so adam
kinzinger goes on a democrat show to go
suck up to another democrat chuck todd i
meet the press and and adam kissinger
announced that he would be dedicating
himself and all of his vast resources
and all of his half-dozen followers and
supporters to campaigning against
republicans even for far left democrats
because the republicans are a threat
to democracy
liz cheney uh
said that in some cases she may have to
help a democrat win against sort of an
anti-democracy republican do you feel
that's what you're going to be doing uh
over the next couple of years yourself
yeah i mean look the biggest issue
not everybody agrees with me certainly
in my party and even democrats that like
to say things like well but you're still
a conservative yeah i'm a conservative
but the bottom line is the biggest
threat right now to our country is
democracy and if you have republicans
that are running against even left-wing
democrats that believe in democracy and
believe in voting
that person should be elected over
somebody who basically would overthrow
the will of the people and ultimately
destroy this country this country cannot
survive outside of democracy it'll turn
into a power struggle between groups of
different races of different ethnicities
of different religions because the thing
that holds us together is this belief
that we can self-govern take that away
this country is a mess and so
republicans that are for that have no
place in office i don't care what their
policy position on taxes are
so pretty much everything adam kinzinger
said there is wrong
he did have this funny line it was a
freudian slippery so the greatest threat
to our country right now is democracy
which i think a lot of the democrats and
the squishy fake republicans would agree
with that's why they're trying to
prevent trump from appearing on a ballot
because they fear democracy they don't
want people to vote for him that's why
they're trying to delegitimize half the
country and say that they're
semi-fascists and they then to kick them
out of the public square and stop them
from having their voices heard because
of the democrats
and the the
cox you know for lack of a better word
the the
court jester conservatives who suck up
to the democrats these guys
are
terrified of democracy
now
the the rest of what adam kenzinger said
is just ridiculous adam kinzinger says
that the country can't survive outside
of democracy first of all the country is
not a pure democracy the founding
fathers wrote at length and the framers
of the constitution wrote at length
about the fears of a pure democracy
because pure democracy would devolve
into mob rule and ironically what they
said would happen as a result of that is
what adam kinzinger says would happen
without
pure democracy adam ginsberg says
without pure democracy then america will
just
delve down into factions and tribes who
attack each other on race and religion
and all the rest of it uh what the
founding fathers believed and what the
framers of the constitution believed is
the opposite they said if we have just a
pure democracy then you're going to have
the mob devolve down into factions and
tribes and warring groups that just
attack each other over their interests
and not in reason discourse that's why
the american regime is a fairly mixed
regime at least at the founding it's got
an executive it's got a kind of
monarchical element to it it's got an
aristocratic element to it
certainly in the us senate and states
rights and then it's got a democratic
element to it a very heavy democratic
element as well so there are a lot of
things going on in the american system
of government uh some of which have been
eroded away and none of which adam
kinzinger understands because he's just
caught up in these stupid headlines he
sounds like lizzo there's no difference
he's congressman lizzo we need the
oppression there is oppression we need
to vote against
and uh i'm a conservative beca because
of why because he says he actually says
the point that we always joke about on
this show
which is that you know just because you
want to cut taxes that doesn't make you
a conservative in many cases it just
makes you a greedy democrat
and adam ginsenger goes look i'm a
conservative okay i love cutting taxes
but just because someone wants to cut
taxes with me i might vote against them
and do what and do what kinzinger says
he's going to vote for people who want
to chop off your kids genitals who want
to kill hundreds of thousands of babies
per year who want to
censor anyone to the right of hillary
clinton who want to flood the country
with illegal aliens all because what all
to stop the mean orange man
who the people support
the mean orange man who got himself
elected president in 2016. at least once
at least one time he did that
the attacks on republicans are really
really ramping up there is a liberal
columnist
named brandon friedman
who is is now saying that when
republicans complain about taxes about
that even when republicans
tailor their criticisms just to taxes
even that is evidence that they're evil
and racist and insurrectionist and they
want to
to overthrow the country i'm not joking
this guy brandon friedman tweets out
this was in response to ted cruz
suggesting that we abolish the irs this
is something that republicans have
campaigned on for a long time
friedman says republicans don't just
hate the irs because it pays for things
like highways and social security
there's history here they hate what it
represents the irs was created in 1862
specifically to fund the civil war
to end slavery and to burn white
supremacy to the ground
abolish the irs
may sound like an innocuous anti-tax
message but it's literally
literally not figuratively literally a
call to defund the u.s military the same
military
that crushed secessionists
the first time it's fundamentally
an anti-government message
the insurrection
continues
don't forget
just want to remind you insurrection
treason these are crimes punishable by
death
and the libs are just casually
cavalierly accusing half of the country
all of us you and me
of a crime of a capital offense
if we even want to lower taxes a little
bit
that's where we are seems like a threat
to democracy to me also his history is a
little bit screwy here
it is true that uh something like the
irs was established in the civil war to
raise money to fight the war but the irs
really begins in earnest in 1913
in the progressive era
and so no when you say we want to cut
taxes or abolish the irs we're not
you're not saying that you want to undo
the civil war you want to destroy the
government or anything like that at all
you're saying you want to abolish the
irs
what does this tell you though this
tells you is one the libs are way more
radical than
even a lot of conservatives recognize
two it tells you that the libs are far
more anti-democracy than a lot of
conservatives even recognize but three
it tells you that
race
race and civil rights that is the
narrative in american politics
every political fight
will in some way be twisted or distorted
to seem like it in some way relates to
race or civil rights
all the weird sex stuff that you've seen
now with the transgender stuff and the
gay rights movement and all the rest of
it
all the language of that was the
language of civil rights
it was the language of the 1960s black
rights movement
were were the new we're the new civil
rights movement they'll even call
themselves that it's all about marriage
equality just like yet interracial
marriage equality that's what you're
going to gay marriage equality now of
course the gay stuff has nothing to do
with black people and frankly black
people disproportionately disapprove of
all the gay sex stuff
doesn't matter everything has to tie
back to race and civil rights in america
cutting taxes abolishing the irs if you
want to abolish the irs you might as
well put a bullet through dr king
yourself what what the hell are you
talking about that is absolutely nothing
to do with race
we want to give tax cuts to black people
too we what are you talking about it's
because that is the dominant narrative
now
it gets a little awkward
that
all the political narratives in america
have to tie back to race and civil
rights because the associated press just
published yesterday
that what it considers to be the most
important story about the federal
reserve bank the federal reserve is
tasked with tackling inflation obviously
not going so well right now
but because no one cares about numbers
or economics or the common good or the
health of the country all anyone wants
to talk about is race the aep decided to
point out that the f the the fed is
tackling inflation with its most diverse
leadership ever
they're saying
the fed's boardroom leadership has
become its most diverse ever there are
more female black and openly gay
officials contributing to the central
bank's interest rate decisions than at
any time in its 109 year history
many are also far less wealthy than the
officials they've replaced and i read
this headline and i thought um is david
duke running the ap now
this is
hold on you're telling me you're telling
me that inflation right now is worse
than ever
and
also the people in charge of inflation
are disproportionately uh minorities
and poor people i don't what are you
trying to tell me that we should only
have rich white guys run the fed is that
that is that is clearly the insinuation
of this article i think cool it with the
racism associated press but they don't
even see it because they're just so
now used to like automatons like robots
just churning out for every single issue
including
interest rates that
historic first ever black trans
gay woman
poor
minority cis trans whatever and they
they don't even realize that what
they're saying is undercutting much of
their own arguments not not a really
good look
not really good look at all now
we have a lot more to this show speaking
of insurrections
speaking of the kind of crazy shrieking
people pulling their hair out versus the
relatively kind of
normal
average generic voter the rest of the
show is continuing now we've got a
really great interview coming up you're
not going to want to miss this
if you're not a member
click the link in the description
and join us we'll see you over there
[Music]
[Music]
you